la chronique de l'écho du jeudi avec
Alice Gastine bonsoir Alice et votre
invité et puis je précise que
Jean-Michel Fourgous donc MP des lcours
et rester avec nous on va parler
économie c'est un sujet qui va forcément
vous intéresser bonsoir à tous ce soir
j'ai décidé de vous parler de
l'auto-entrepreneuriat un statut qui
fête ses 4 ans cette année un statut qui
a été adopté par plus de 900000 Français
et 18000 personnes dans les ivelines mon
invité est Jean-Marc borotti bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes donc à la maison de
l'entreprise de 50 ans en Yveline vous
accompagnez des créateurs d'entreprise
et notamment des auto-entrepreneurs vous
en avez accompagné plus de 500 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui quel est le profil de ces
personnes le statut auto-entrepreneur un
statut qui a permis de rassembler
beaucoup de personnes autour d'un projet
d'une initiative économique on va dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a une typologie euh de
porteur de projet à 45 % de demandeur
d'emploi et 35 % de salariés le reste
étant essentiellement des retraités ou
des étudiants est-ce que ça marche
est-ce que ça marche vous avez su est-ce
que ça marche véritablement on veut tous
savoir alors évidemment la mission de la
maison d'entreprise et de toute l'équipe
c'est d'accompagner he cette initiative
économique c'est de permettre à ses
futur
entrepreneurs de leur apporter des
outils des méthodes formation conseils
pour permettre de consolider leur
activité quelles sont les difficultés
principales on pense aux relations avec
les banques notamment alors évidemment
principaux freins à l'entrepreneuriat
déjà premier
frein comment dire l'apport financier
évidemment le banquier va PE avoir du
mal à prêter des sommes très importantes
avec des plafonds qui vont de 32000
32600 € jusqu'à 800500 € ça peut être un
réel frein de de pouvoir obtenir un
financement au niveau des banques cela
dit aujourd'hui il existe d'autres
dispositifs au sein de la maison
d'entreprise différents types de
partenaires euh pour des publics
spécifiques allocateurs des minimas
sociaux des prês 0 % par ex voilà tout à
fait pour les demandeurs d'emploi ou
d'autres outils qui existent pour
permettre si vous voulez de faire effet
de levier sur le financement de projets
liés à l' auto-entrepreneurian Michel
Fourgous Nicolas Sarkozi pendant la
campagne présidentielle en mai dernier
souhaitait généraliser le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur justement à
l'ensemble des artisans pendant la
campagne c'était une bonne idée ben
parce que la meilleure mesure contre le
chômage c'est de développer la culture
entrepreneuriale qu'on retrouve bien
dans ce statut comme vous le dites c'est
ça c'est pas des mesures de l'état des
administration l'emploi c'est une
culture d'entrepreneuriat qu'il faut
développer c'est aussi le but de de et
c'est une réussite quandme 900000
900000 en 4 ans il faut reconnaître que
les Français sont appropriés ça fa voir
la durée de vie ensuite est-ce que
justement ces entreprises qui se crée en
statut d'auto-entrepreneur fonctionneors
JeanMarc borgotti finalement au bout
d'un moment les auto-entrepreneurs qui
ont du succès peuvent aller vers
d'autres statuts comme une SL ou
aujourd'hui on des nom un peu plus de 70
entreprises auto-entrepreneurs qui se
sont développé où là on les accompagne
aujourd'hui sur des nouvelles notions
créer son premier emploi la
déductibilité au niveau des charges la
notion de TVA auto-entreprendre c'est
avant tout entreprendre c'est respecter
différentes règles fondamentaux liées à
la création d'entreprise
premieréquilibre c'est l'adéquation auu
du projet est-ce que le porteur de
projet a la capacité d'entreprendre
force faiblesse menace opportunités
deuxième équilibre l'étude de marché y
a-t-il un réel potentiel pour mon
activité qui sont mes concurrents quel
tarif je vais proposer produits services
adaptés euh ma communication est-ce que
j'ai les bons outils est-ce que j'ai le
non commercial pour pour voir impacter
mes clients les notions ensuite en
équilibre de ressources besoin on
revient notamment quels sont les
investissements nécessaires au démarage
de l'activité les ressources les
financements les prêts bancaires et
dernier point la rentabilité chiffre
d'affaires charge voilà on se rend bien
compte qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'éléments à prendre en compte avant de
se lancer dans entrepreneuriat et on est
allé demander aux cinquantinois si ils
envisageaient de se lancer dans
l'auto-entrepreneuriat un
jour euh non pas du tout c'est vrai que
j'ai pas l'ambition aujourd'hui de
d'être auto-entrepreneur moi je m'étais
enseigné je trouvais que voilà on est
limité sur on est limité sur le chiffre
d'affaires il y a après pour pour la
retraite il y a quelques quelques soucis
pour pour les trimestres valider ses
trimestres des choses comme ça donc je
pense que c'est plus un complément de
revenu et ou peut-être une une première
approche pour se lancer après sur un
statut de sa srl mais c'est une bonne
approche c'est une bonne approche mais
je pense pas qu'en soi ce soit une
activité et un statut qu'on puisse
garder pendant des années quoi non je
pense pas non pour quelle raison parce
qu'il faut être super rigoureux et que
ça doit être quand même pas très
simple voilà je sais pas niveau de
l'organisation des papiers oui voilà
c'est ça oui au point de vue
administratif ça doit être un peu
compliqué je pense non pour quelle
raison parce que le secteur du où je
travaille est pas forcément propiss a
j'ai pas la carrure pour ouais oui je
pense qu'il faut être sû de soi et
pouvoir être confiant en l'avenir donc
pour le moment non voilà et plus tard
peut-être oui on sait jamais mais
Jean-Michel forgous on enevient à ce que
vous disiez les Français ont peur de
l'entreprise aussi peur de se lancer
peut-être c'est ça qui manque en France
oui mais il y a il y a une telle
défiance de l'entreprise qu'on apprend
déjà aux jeunes à l'école regardez nos
professeurs d'économie souvent bon qui
ne viennent pas d'ailleurs de
l'entreprise pour ça qu'on on a demandé
nous un stage de 6 mois pour que les
d'économie comprenn l'économie réel bon
et qui transmettent ça à nos enfants
parce que la façon de sortir de réussir
de faire réussir un pay aujourd'hui
c'est cette culture entrepreneuriale
puisque c'est la première phase parce
que en dessous de 100000 enfin c'est
jusqu'à presque 100000 € mais après
après quand vous passez à la deuxième
phase quand vous êes passé à cette
première phase deè vous créez vraiment
une vraie entreprise avec des des
créations d'emploi voilà c'est une face
donc c'est culturellement une très bonne
initiative et merci de l'accompagner
d'ailleurs